mais peut-être pas le bon jour si vous
comptiez partir en vacances aujourd'hui
la cgt cheminots et certains syndicats
les aéroports de paris appelle à la
grève les cheminots réclament une hausse
des salaires des embauches et je cite à
de réelles négociations pour un statut
social de haut niveau chez adp on
demande de retrait du fameux pacte le
plan d'adaptation des conditions de
travail
sncf sur le trafic sort aujourd'hui
quasi normal en revanche avec quelques
retards sont possibles dans les
aéroports de la capitale
et on parle de cette grève justement
dans les gares de france avec et mathieu
bolle-reddat secrétaire général de la
cgt cheminots de versailles
bonjour mathieu baudry d'un merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
j'ai dire vous appelé aujourd'hui à la
grève pour une hausse des salaires et
plus d'embauchés bien ça oui alors
effectivement il ya la question des
salaires et des embauches l'arrêt des
restructurations l'arrêt des
suppressions de postes c'est une
évidence
il ya aussi vous ne l'avez pas si tu es
donc je me permets de le citer la
question de l'arrêt du processus des
privatisations qui ont lieu tous azimuts
en france actuellement et qui vont
continuer s'accélérer avec le résultat
des dernières régionales que ça soit en
paca dans les hauts de france ou si nous
en ile-de-france avec l'agenda de
privatisation de valérie pécresse la
vente à la découpe du réseau ferré
national ligne par ligne au ter ou
transilien qui va être nuisible pour les
cheminots c'est une évidence mais qui va
être aussi nuisible pour les usagers
donc c'est une lutte de grande ampleur
donc oui à la question des salaires trop
bas qui soit indécent que des salariés à
1300 à 1500 à 1800 euros et qui ont sept
ans de gel salarial dans la gueule
réclament des augmentations de salaires
d'autant qu'on était des travailleurs
essentiel de la deuxième ligne comme
disait monsieur mâcon pendant tout le
kobe nous on a continué à travailler
assuré le service public mais la
question des suppressions de postes la
question des embauches
elle est fondamentale aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas faire tourner
servi servières de qualité au service
des usagers que ça soit dans transports
ferrés de marchandises de voyageurs 100
salariés sur personnel à un moment donné
ce n'est pas possible
donc il n'est pas le moment de faire des
économies de bouts de chandelle
sur le spi rouge hier au moment où on
parle de d'enjeux écologiques de
transport doux de te voir développer le
transport doux du grand paris chez nous
et c'est ce n'est certainement pas le
moment de supprimer des postes bien le
contraire alors mathieu drida
l'unsa ferroviaire la cfdt cheminots sud
rail n'ont pas souhaité s'associer
injustement mouvement et dénonce une
grève
fourtou est ce que est ce que vous le
regrettez ok je vais pas commenter
monsieur dees un certain nombre de
syndicats notamment et de syndicats
traditionnellement de non grévistes
comme la cfdt et l'unsa bon pour sud
rail c'est pas si clair que ça dans
certaines régions notamment la vienne
sur paris rive gauche
ils appellent à la grève aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est aussi des questions de
d'agenda revendicatif de stratégie ses
parts à moins de vraiment commenter ce
qu'ils disent je pense que nous
l'aurions cent restants aux syndicats on
s'adresse aux cheminots on s'adresse aux
usagers et on essaie de construire un
front una front de lutte justement
contre la régression sociale mais aussi
contre la régression du service
ferroviaire en france et je vous parlais
des privatisations
le le danger qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est
que des fonds de pension privés vont
rentrer aujourd'hui au capital de dans
certaines lignes
je prends l'exemple même des lignes qui
serait resté à la sncf mais vous en avez
parlé sur votre antenne
je me souviens à quelques semaines à
nice notamment où l'appel d'offres a été
remporté par la sncf et donc
on pense que c'est la sncf qui va
continuer de faire le transport
ferroviaire en paca notamment dans la
région niçoise et vintimille ryan on se
sera transférée à sa boîte privée à ces
boîtes privées notamment à une boîte
qu'on connaît bien et bien connu de nos
services qui s'appelle keolis et qui est
détenu effectivement majoritairement par
la sncf mais aussi à 49 % par la caisse
des dépôts et consignations du québec je
vous le donne en mille c'est à dire que
c'est le fonds de pension des riches
pensionnés nord américain qui va
aujourd'hui capter l'argent du service
public au lieu qu'ils soient réinjectées
dans le service tooway ça va être bien
sûr mauvais pour lui ce n'est pas ce que
vous demandez des calmes productive
c'est une évidence
on est en grève on est en lutte contre
ça mais c'est aussi une catastrophe pour
les usagers parce que cet argent qui va
être mis au pot pour le service public
va être captés finalement pour des fonds
de pension privés ne va pas être remis
pour le développement pour
l'investissement dans le service public
au sperme et donc aujourd'hui pour qu'on
crève le mur du silence là dessus c'est
ce qu'on essaye de faire avec la
fédération des cheminots crever le mur
du silence sur le sujet et marquer des
points sur ces négociations qui ne
s'ouvrent toujours pas avec la direction
au sujet des embauches des
restructurations et des salaires et
mathieu balle reda vous nous parler
justement de crever ce mur du silence où
nous dit à l'instant que qu'aucune
discussion pour l'instant n'est n'est
prévue avec la direction est ce que ça
veut dire que la grève pourrait être
reconduite dans les jours ou les
semaines à venir a coûté c'est toujours
à mettre en débat avec les salariés nous
notre agenda c'est les intérêts des
salariés aussi puisqu'on est dans une
entreprise de services musique les
intérêts des usagers mais à un moment
donné vous parler de la grève y compris
de cette date du 1er juillet c'est pas
tout à fait une date de départ en
vacances à il faut pas exagérer non plus
on est à jeudi ce n'est pas c'est pas
les grands départs contre connais un peu
le ferroviaire d'autant que l'école
n'est pas fini je pense pas que les gens
à rester sur des courts bon donc on met
cette première date dans le paysage
puisque la spéculation mais c'est
et jean birsa marathon mais aujourd'hui
on est contraint à la grève pour essayer
de se faire entendre parce que on n'a
pas deux mais cotation vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et vis-à-vis du patronat
donc c'est pas notre pote à un moment
donné on est contraint à se défendre
c'est ça aussi le message qu'on veut
envoyer et quand on entend que le
président macron qui n'a pas l'air
d'avoir retenu les leçons de son mandat
son mandat c'est quand même deux grèves
générales de cheminots allemande gilet
jaune et c'est un mandat de guérilla
sociale bon où il a été contraint par la
puissance de la grève
vu la situation sanitaire qui arrivait à
retirer son projet de réforme des
retraites qu'on entend le président
mâcon faire dans la provocation et dire
bah après de cette prime douillot
régional de dire bah du coup ça veut
dire qu'il faut que je fasse la réforme
des retraites et 64 ans pour tous dès le
mois d'octobre dans la loi de finances
de sécurité sociale bon ben je pense
qu'il n'est pas là pour jouer
l'apaisement et la construction du
dialogue avec les salariés les
organisations syndicales
parce que c'est une évidence et
aujourd'hui laurent bras la prévenue une
secrétaire et des rations et d'autres
organisations de la cgt il y aura une
réponse à la hauteur des attaques
les cheminots sont prêts et bien
d'autres corporations sont prêtes à
répondre à toute attaque qui seraient
tels sur le pacte social sur la sécurité
sociale bien sûr et sur particulièrement
sur les retraites
merci beaucoup monsieur volerait d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl on
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la cgt cheminots de
versailles merci beaucoup